the sacrifice in afghanistan is seared
into our national consciousness
when they're saying that like they're
surprised that this happened then it
clearly shows that they haven't spoke to
enough boots on the ground soldiers a
group of former soldiers who fought in
afghanistan
watching the parliamentary debate at a
drop-in center for veterans
i do feel for boris i think he's he's
just been left with it it was it was
problems
he's inherited the problems there was
support for the prime minister but a
feeling also that mps don't really know
what the problems are just in general
the way politicians taught they don't
make any sense do they whereas a lot of
us that were there you know we can tell
you
the sort of
the sensible answers over if that makes
sense
this is what afghanistan means to daniel
two tours with the second royal tank
regiment and would do it all again
craig monahan feels the same about his
time with two rifles
his career ended with a roadside bomb
that wiped three years of his memory
after a painful recovery craig set up
what is a rare facility in the uk a
small charity center open each day to
give help and support to veterans like
alex robinson
ex-raf regiment two deployments to
afghanistan still keen to talk about it
my message will hate me for saying this
but she hates hearing about afghan or
being because she doesn't understand it
so being able to come in here and talk
to people and just have a laugh and so
being able to just walk in there and
have a good crack with him it's just it
just relieves that stress
12 years on from his devastating
injuries
craig
says help is needed as much as ever how
big is the demand for veterans now with
everything that's going on with
afghanistan in a minute we've seen a 200
rising request of counselling and that's
just in the last week so there needs to
be more centers like this where people
could come in and get the help they need
yeah completely uh otherwise the issues
that are already facing the veterans
community will spiral out of control
the center has ambitious plans to expand
its services while mps debate
these veterans just want to be with
people who understand what they've been
through
gerard tub sky news
manchester right that we should